General Sir Richard Barons is former
commander of the Joint Forces command
and he's with us now hi it's good to see
you as always thanks for joining us on
the program the Russians say they've got
it what's your best view
so the Russians have taken the last
high-rise Residential Building in the
west of bakmut so they control the city
center but the Ukrainian forces are on
The High Ground north and south of the
city and still have a road leading in
tobacco so to all intents and purposes
it's Fallen to Russia but the Ukraine
military still have some control over
the area of the city
um so much life lost on both sides
fighting for this city why is it so
important
well originally it was important to the
Russians because they thought if they
took back moot then they will be able to
open up and seize the rest of the donets
region and one of the outcomes of this
battle so far is that's clearly not
happened but it's become this iconic
battle between the two sides where they
have just thrown thousands of people in
into the fight and the net result is
it's um it's essentially a a draw but
the losses on both sides are phenomenal
and and the key thing that's come out of
this is the Wagner group is now coming
out of the fight at least for a while
it's been broken by bankmoot
lost so many
um soldiers haven't they during this
fighting what what happens next as far
as Russia is concerned and we're still
waiting for this spring offensive from
the other side yeah so that absolutely
is is the key so Russia knows that the
Ukraine is about to amount an offensive
they they may suspect they know where
but it it isn't clear to anybody else
right now and what was interesting about
the Battle for back moot in the closing
stages is that Russia had to move
precious reserves of people and
ammunition to stop the Ukraine movement
to the north and south of the city so
that will have handicapped their
preparations for the offensive but the
next big thing will be whenever it comes
the Ukraine offensive
yeah and they we've seen obviously um
excuse me president zielinski over the
weekend G7 Summit um in Japan with all
his friends as he describes them um
he'll be very happy this morning about
the news about f-16s
he will but we should recognize that
f-16s will take about 18 months to
become combat effective in in Ukraine so
what this signals is an expectation on
the part of the G7 and others and
president zielinski but whatever the
outcome of the offensive they're about
to amount this war will go on into next
year
oh my goodness um that's not something
that any side wants to hear I'm sure
um what difference will the f-16s make
zelenski promising not to use them on
Russian soil
so it's a very complex fourth generation
aircraft it will give Ukraine a decisive
advantage over the Russian Air Force and
indeed Russian Ground Forces if they get
to the right threshold of capability and
have the family of ammunition that make
the aircraft so so effective so it would
turn the battle in the skies in favor of
Ukraine when Ukraine has enough of the
aircraft enough competence with it and
enough of a family of missiles that make
it a really effective weapon what's
wrong with the Ukrainian Air Force
there's so much wrong with it it's
certainly full of spirit but it's it's
aircraft are mostly Russian aircraft and
therefore well known to the Russians so
they've not been able to throw the
Russian Air Force out of the Skies
everywhere and they've relied very
heavily on on their ground air defenses
f-16s will give them the ability to take
Ukraine air power over Russian forces in
Ukraine that will be a game changer
which countries which other countries do
you think will send fighter jets so I
would think there are a lot of NATO
members who are equipped with the F-16
who will be now thinking whether they
can step forward and provide aircraft it
would be surprising in the circumstances
if some offers weren't forthcoming quite
quite quickly but part of the issue for
NATO countries that give f-16s is well
what do they now have instead do they do
they come up the queue for the fifth
generation F-35 for example
[Music]
ukrainians does that mean NATO has
entered this conflict
so the vital Point here is there is an
undertaking for president zielinski that
NATO aircraft like the F-16 would not be
used over Russia and that's a cardinal
point for those people that would
provide those aircraft because one of
the key points since February last year
is that this must remain a war between
Ukraine and Russia in Russia guys it's
already largely irrelevant they see the
war they see their struggle in this war
as a result of the fact they're fighting
30 countries not just Ukraine and they
will accept that these aircrafts haven't
and won't be used over Russia but they
still think they're at war with NATO
what if an F-16
um hits a Target even by accident on
Russian soil what happens then
well I think if it's a a one-off
incident both sides will want to talk it
down because we should recognize that
Russia absolutely knows that
strategically it cannot take on an angry
and mobilized NATO and such is the state
of the Russian army right now that 95 of
it is focused on on Ukraine so Russia
has no interest in this becoming a war
with nature because it's it's bound to
lose but on the other hand other NATO
countries they don't want to war with
Russia either because of the effects on
their economy and their security so but
everyone has an interest in this war
being territorially defined to Ukraine
at least for now
by just receiving a few helmets from the
Germans now he's got f-16s with these
persuasive Powers why is he not involved
in peace negotiations
I think the honest truth of this is in
this war neither sides have run out of
the will to fight neither side is one
neither side is lost neither side feels
they need to give up yet so there's no
scope for peace talks whilst people
think they can achieve their objective
by fighting and that is currently the
case with both sides
can they achieve their objectives by
fighting do you think so
so I think we'll find over the course of
this summer and into the winter that it
becomes increasingly clear to both sides
that changing the the size and shape of
the current front line becomes very
difficult very costly and maybe the
attitudes will change when people feel
they can't win by fighting but we're a
really really long way from that right
now okay it's always good to have your
expertise on the program thank you
Kim